[Music]
Lady Gaga performed on the show last
night and you this is a coincidence you
did a sex scene with Lady gaga
on American Horror Story hmm curious
you're married what does your husband
say when you say when you tell him you
come home from work and say I just did a
sex scene with Lady gaga
was he cool with it I don't remember
coming home and telling him that but I
do remember you didn't tell him I was
worked pretty good what could I do I
refuse
yeah you know I didn't tell him you know
I had to sign to the you know and they
call you and say oh we need you to sign
on a nudity waiver you're like okay yeah
what's gonna happen who's doing what to
whom right you know right oh okay I'll
go for that but I just you know wait it
until the night of and said come on I
want you to see something so he perched
himself he didn't tell him so you waited
till the the show air until then and so
I'm showing it and I have the remote and
he's like whoa oh what's about to happen
you know just like what pawpaws what's
going on with you oh you gonna be all
right you know and so uh dude just eased
him into it so what you're basically
saying is you went frame by frame
[Laughter]
you